even if I'm not speaking the language
well and I'm struggling I can just have
fun with it at any level I don't need to
be perfectly fluent and I think that's a
big thing that I preach which is you
don't need to be the best you just have
to have fun with it it's a hobby for
everyone some people get so strung out
and so annoyed and worried at becoming a
perfectionist and especially when they
get in front of a camera so I try to not
do that I couldn't agree more I think
100 that's true and the other fun thing
about being a language simp is that you
can pursue five languages and none of
the languages get jealous whereas if you
are pursuing five women you might start
getting into trouble at some point yes
I've never pursued five women but five
languages at the same time yes I'm sure
you've had the same experience that you
start a language you leave it it's
always there it's like a girlfriend that
you can go and visit whenever you want
it's not a love affair but you go there
and you enjoy being together well as
long as you didn't move on to another
woman but yeah I understand depends what
do you mean by move on to it